السفر بعد جائع كورونا وبدون اجراءات
اخترازيه حلم انتظره الملايين من الصينيين
تحديدا ثلاث سنوات صعبه وطويله مرت بها
البلاد التي كانت بؤره للوباء الذي غير
مجرى حياتهم وحياه العالم باسره بعض
اسابيع فقط من تخلي بكين عن سياستها
الصارمه لاحتواء الوباء والتي صاحبها
تسجيل معدلات قياسيه في الاصابات اجراء
جديد تم اتخاذه في خطوه ايضا لامتصاص
الاستياء الشعبي من الاغلاقات تمثل برفع
قيود السفر والتنازل عن الاختبار والحجر
الصحي للمسافرين خصوصا الوافدين الى الصين
تعديل سياسه التاشيرات للاجانب بطريقه
علميه
اعتمادا على تطور الوضع الوبائي
لا مزيد من الاجراءات المرهقه لكل
المسافرين والوافدين للصين فشركات السياحه
والسفر وبمجرد اعلان الحكومه عن هذا
القرار عرفت اقبالا كبيلا قبيل اعاده فتح
حدود البلاد في الثامن من يناير للعام
المقبل
لقد كنت متحمسه للغايه عندما سمعت الخبر
كان غير متوقع كنت اتطلع اليها كنت اسافر
كثيرا وانا متعطش للسفر
قد اوقفوا خطط سفرهم لسنوات لذلك ستكون
هناك زياده هائله في عدد الاشخاص
المسافرين
على مواقع السفر واظهرت بياناته منصه
السفر تضعف عمليات البحث عن وجهات السفر
في غضون نصف ساعه فقط من تداول خبر رفع
قيود الحجر الصحي وتصدر التايلند واليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه الوجهات
الثمن من يناير من العام المقبل يمثل خطوه
حاسمه لاعاده فتح الصين امام العالم وهنا
سيتمكن القاده الاجانب مره اخرى من السفر
الى بكين دون ان ينحصر في فقاعه صحيه خطوه
كبيره اتخذتها الحكومه الصينيه لاحتواء
الاستياء الشعبي وبحث السياحه من جديد
وايضا لتدارك الاضرار الاقتصاديه المستمره
منذ العام 2020 والتي تسببت في ركود لم
يسبق مثيل في الاقتصاد الصيني